das habe ich auch noch nicht gehört
lebensfreude verursacht durch pizza das
sagt jedenfalls kommt es gibt für sie
noch zwei andere kunde coole games und
süße haustiere
warum sie dann aber 101 dalmatiner
klauen will und sich daraus einen mantel
nähen lassen möchte das jetzt in fragen
lautet kultur also die lücken sind meine
fragen die grünen ich dir das kurz geben
ist es nicht ein bisschen peinlich dass
du immer noch in seinem kinderzimmer
haus ich wohne in einer studenten-wg das
ist kein kinderzimmer wenn es so
aussieht dann ja ich lebe halt
außergewöhnlich toll kein geld mehr was
besseres zu leisten
bist du eigentlich schon ergraut oder
warum fährst du dir immer die haare
nein ich habe noch eine original farbe
ist hier hinten irgendwo also eigentlich
ist es doch ich habe einfach nur wie
nennt man das straßenköter braun oder so
was also die haarfarbe ist einfach
langweilig und ich weiß nicht wann ich
mich schon die haare färben ist auch
irgendwo ein markenzeichen geworden und
deswegen mache ich das und wenn ich
graue haare kriegen würde da würd ich
mir so kapeller die will mäßig würde so
eine eine seite graue und andererseits
schwarze und dann würde ich 101
dalmatiner weiten clown und mehr manche
daraus machen ist ein kleinflugzeug okay
ich habe bisher
m
hältst du dich jetzt für was besseres
nur weil du ständig im fernsehen bist
wie wirkt sich aus nein natürlich nicht
also es ist schon cool im fernsehen aber
ich bin ja nur bei einsfestival was den
spartensender ist und ich glaube wenn
jetzt irgendwie prosieben oder rtl oder
so was ankommt da würde ich auch sagen
nee also ich bin jetzt nicht ein fernseh
mensch sondern das ist ja auch alles das
sind ja auch coole typen es ist ein
projekt das sie gerne unterstützen
wollten und wenn die keinen bock mehr
auf mich haben dann muss ich nicht
weiter beim fernsehen bleiben dass das
wären wie viele leute gucken
mir wurde gesagt dass es läuft
quotenmäßig besser als sonst als das was
sonst da laufen was gut ist glaube ich
aber es ist jetzt nicht das highlight
und es gibt glaube ich andere sendungen
die besser sind aber die interessieren
sich für das projekt und das ist ja dann
schon das ist das coole an
öffentlich-rechtlichen die machen das
dann einfach scheiß auf quote ist ja
auch nicht immer so ich sonst gäb's ich
glaube das große frühlingsfest der
volksmusik gibt
wie hast du es über all die jahre und
trotz seines erfolgs geschafft immer du
selbst zu bleiben weil ich schon damit
angefangen habe ich selbst zu sein als
ich berühmt geworden bin keine ahnung
also ich hab bin halt mit dem berühmt
geworden wie ich bin also ich hab mich
jetzt nicht dafür verändert meinen job
zu kriegen sondern die job leute sind zu
mir gekommen haben gesagt es irgendwie
witzig und du bist cool
willst du bei uns arbeiten so und das
war irgendwie sinnlos gewesen mich für
die zu verändern und wenn jetzt ein
jobangebot kommt und sagt hey du müsste
es aber ganz anders sein als du nicht
bist um für uns zu arbeiten einfach
nicht da nicht arbeiten also das ist der
einzige unterschied jetzt ist
komfortabel
ja also wenn man berühmt ist kann man
sich erlauben einen job abzulehnen
mit dem 2
woher hast du deine lebensfreude
ja ich trotzdem natürlich for happiness
keine ahnung durch die arbeit und
dadurch dass ich in meiner arbeit ich
selbst sein kann
durch freunde durch süße haustiere durch
coole games alles mögliche also man muss
es nur wollen gibt ja auch leute sind
einfach die primiz ihn sich immer weiter
selber ins loch rein und wenn ich merke
okay mir geht es jetzt schlecht ich bin
jetzt da ich mache jetzt mal eine woche
nichts und das hilft mir dann auch also
man muss sich auch selber mal so ein
bisschen was golden und sich nicht
bewegen und nur pizza essen
das hilft aber nur ist auch lonza ist
lebensfreude dass das sieht man ja auch
auf dauer runter ich glaube es ist nein
nein
was hast du für leben ben khalifa zieht
runter das ist so deutsch
ich habe das nicht verstanden nein was
ist ein satz macht nicht das pizza essen
an sich aber dass die ganze zeit dass
man ja nur ein scherz also mit humor wie
sich die seien dann natürlich nicht nur
fordern sondern auch einfach mal was für
sich machen und sich das auch erlauben
und sich nicht immer selber runter
ziehen also das leben ist voll cool es
gibt so viele coole sachen und selbst
wenn es nur kleinigkeiten sind wir mal
eben stück pizza essen oder game spielen
keine ahnung oder sich auf eine serie
freuen die man lange nicht gesehen hat
so kleinigkeiten
ok dann würde ich dir noch viele
kleinigkeiten denke ich danke dir wissen
bis dahin ein anderer youtuber mit
ungewöhnlichen thesen elf leute im
fragen lotto der sagt gewalt ist
unterhaltsam und wenn er eine ziemlich
verrückte truppe sehen wollt dann sind
das die 257 dass die im fragen lotto
sagen wir machen kiz nicht nach das oder
das oder was anderes
bis dann blättern